we check it in with Hanna the accepted
Islam about a year ago
I was not very religious I was born in a
really Orthodox family and I hated being
a Jehovah's Witness I hated religion I
hated all those leave what CNN Fox News
Twitter Instagram puts out about Muslim
I thought the same I was ignorant I
thought that they were bad people I felt
scared at first then meeting these
Muslims meeting going to I offend
that's my must [ __ ] seeing how they were
how they treated me how they treated
other how they put everyone else first
and they're the last one that was
something meaningful to me because I
started to see for the first time what
was unity for the first time so read do
your research and a crap read
how's this gonna go stars
knowledge analyst for me it has been
something magnificent the way that Islam
did not only become a believer but it
became my way of life the way that I do
everything and it is just incredible the
way that I consider that I did not
actually pick it was even finding out my
my linen is my mother's many is where
last names Medina and it never even came
up to me it took me a year to you
started to study to learn to get well
grounding the Dean and you see what
happens if you're not getting walk
rounded you don't know your Dean's then
you don't
from the roots of Islam but you did that
and you're still here with us a year
later this summer
inshallah adenosyl and one year seminar
- then it could read just like it
couldn't read read the Quran read this
enough let that be your guide let that
be the judge thank you very much